que la France était un des pays avec sa
filière nucléaire qui produisait
l'électricité en abondance à un coût
moindre en Europe et là on se retrouve à
expliquer que parce que il y a eu un
accord politique entre les Verts et
la gauche entre François Hollande
monsieur Macron idem qu'on a sacrifié
saborder notre filière nucléaire vous
savez qu'avec un parc nucléaire qui
tourne à plein régime EDF produit 480 to
à l'année là avec la moitié du parc
nucléaire on rade à cause d'eux et après
avoir fermé Fessenheim d'entretien ça
peut remonter à 10 ans effectivement
manque d'entretien parce que leur
objectif était de de fermer au petit à
petit la filière nucléaire et donc on
voit bien que d'avoir
de ne pas avoir assuré l'entretien de
nos de nos centrales nucléaires d'avoir
fermé Fessenheim on se retrouve dans une
situation on n'est plus en mesure de
répondre aux besoins d'électricité des
Français ce gouvernement est coupable
coupable si aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
répondre à la demande des Français c'est
de la faute de François Hollande
Emmanuel Macron et Bruno Le Maire
compris qu'il devrait avoir honte après
avoir servi le gouvernement dans lequel
nous étions après avoir mis en place
flamant ville après avoir initié le
programme Astrid justement sur la
filière nucléaire sur l'innovation dans
la filière nucléaire d'avoir contribué
en étant dans ce gouvernement à saborder
notre filière nucléaire si il se montre
aujourd'hui en col roulé j'espère que la
glace se brise quand il se regarde dans
le miroir c'est honteux de dire aux
Français il va falloir baisser votre
chauffage et le directeur de RTE le
réseau de transport d'électricité qui
explique sur une autre chaîne que si on
a une plaque électrique avec quatre feux
ne vous servez pas de vos quatre
feuilles en même temps en France non
mais c'est honteux